the wait is over the nfl pro bowl is
here finally this weekend in las vegas
joining us now live nfl vice president
of events matt shapiro matt thank you so
much for being on the program this
morning your ad allegiant the source of
it all we've been waiting since 2020 for
the pro bowl now you're finally here but
what initially brought you to las vegas
yeah thanks so much for having me the
pro bowl is a really unique event
where it's important to have both a fan
experience that's really positive and a
great experience for our players and las
vegas is a perfect destination for that
we've seen that so far in the excitement
about ticket sales for sunday as well as
a player experience overall
oh we definitely have uh all the hotel
rooms for all the people who are coming
into town as well we've kind of given a
little preview a little snippet here
there and everywhere about some of the
things that are being going to be going
on for fans that may look a little
different than we've seen so go ahead
and give us the lay of the land what can
we expect what will look different than
in years past
yeah so um throughout the week we're
really stationed at las vegas ballpark
which is an incredible
place to be we have our pro bowl skills
showdown that that will be on this
afternoon and then we we've got three
great days of practice on thursday
friday and saturday and it all
culminates here at allegion stadium on
sunday and fans can get their tickets at
pro bowl dot com sunday will be an
amazing game with 88 of our absolute
best players at this beautiful new
stadium so we couldn't be more excited
and i have to ask you what is the one
what is the one big draw what looks
different here than anywhere else
i mean just looking around it certainly
looks different here in las vegas which
we're really excited about um on sunday
too we're doing some really new elements
within the game which which we're super
uh looking forward to whether it's our
charitable incentive programs where
players will be able to give donations
to causes that they care about based on
their in-game performance touchdowns
tackles field goals and some of the
rules changes that that we're doing in
game this year that we're sort of using
the pro bowl as a laboratory for for
football experimentation so there should
be a lot of new elements this year with
some of our absolute best players oh boy
that is interesting especially with the
world changes and some of the things
that have been uh discussed as of late
matt thank you so much we are really
excited to have the pro bowl here in las
vegas thanks man